shocking news out of New York it turns
out when you release a lot of criminals
from prison for no reason they commit
more crimes this is the unbelievable new
conclusion that the geniuses at the New
York City government have discovered you
remember at the beginning of the corona
virus pandemic when everyone told us
that the corona virus was SuperDuper
serious it was going to kill everybody
who was so dangerous we had to let
people out of prison for it we had to
let them out of prison presumably so
they could show up by the thousands and
thousands and riot and loot and protest
at that point of course coronavirus was
no longer dangerous though it's now
dangerous again that the riots are
ebbing that's all news for a little bit
later in the show initially we were told
that we had to let those criminals out
of prison because it would be cruel not
to let them out they'll finally be
law-abiding citizens well turns out of
the 2500 defendants sprung from Rikers
250 have been arrested again already and
they've been rehearsed in 450 times just
in the last few weeks during the
pandemic the left is making the same
mistake that they have made for the past
300 years at least they think that
politics can be used to fundamentally
change human nature well we'll find out
why that is just completely untrue I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael Nolt
show
[Music]
all right lot to get to today we've got
to get to updates from the peaceful
riots what it means the celebrities have
to weigh in some pollsters have weighed
in as well
kind of surprising news for the
President and for Joe Biden maybe maybe
not depends how you've been looking at
this all along we'll get to that in one
second first though I've got to ask a
question of all of you this is
completely forget about the riots this
is just on the culture turns out we've
found out over the weekend SpongeBob
SquarePants
is a homosexual we found out that Elmer
Fudd the most famous hunter in all of
cartoon history no longer carries a gun
we found that paw patrol another cartoon
is problematic because it involves cops
which cartoon will next be destroyed by
the woke mob please let me know I need
the is it gonna be Bugs Bunny is it
gonna be the Jetsons is it gonna be The
Flintstones is it gonna be a cartoon
from sooner than 50 years ago
I don't know you let me know let me know
in the comments section I also have to
give a shout-out to chappie the third
who commented on our show I guess I'm
Thursday and was was kind of reacting to
some of these woke liberals and he said
I'm 15 and compared to these Liberty
it's protesting I feel like an absolute
alpha male it's oh you probably you do
in the land of the blind the one-eyed
man is king and the liberal protests
haven't gotten any better over the past
few days we were told oh it's fine it's
ending don't worry about it we're giving
these peaceful wonderful rioters space
to breathe and to express themselves and
it turns out they're still expressing
themselves and they're expressing
themselves by breaking things and
stealing things and shaking cop cars
here's just a little update take a
listen from the peaceful riots you can
hear people screaming someone throws a
giant metal trashcan at a cop car then
okay the light goes on the cop car well
still throwing stuff there are at least
hundreds of people around it
and so what's the cop duties the cop
arrest them now they're still throwing
stuff at the cop car and the cop is
caught in this impossible position one
he doesn't have any backup so they
probably rip him to shreds that he got
out of the car but but - even if he did
use force the woke mob would tear him
apart and tell him that it was unjust so
the cops just leave and the mobs run the
streets only one conclusion from this we
need overwhelming force to put down the
riots we need the police departments to
use overwhelming force to put down the
riots we need the civil government to
back up the police departments in using
overwhelming for us to put down the
riots and if the local governments won't
do it in the state governments won't do
it the federal government needs to come
in we need to fund the police okay
you've heard other F words about the
police we need to fund the police okay
and we need to state simple truths as
well here's one very simple truth the
police are a force for good period full
stop
that's it I know that's controversial
these days it is insane that that is
controversial these days
the police are a force for good and the
police when they're doing their jobs
must use force now we're being told that
the police should not use force the
entire job of the police is to use force
you cannot have law enforcement without
force it's right there in the middle of
the word that's the job a lot of
confusion arises from the left getting
something totally backwards here the the
traditional view of law enforcement is
that law enforcement exists because
crime exists that's why you always need
law enforcement even when civil disorder
kind of falls apart you still have
groups at least acting as the police
because you need to enforce the law you
need to enforce order okay that's the
traditional view but the leftist view is
backwards the leftist view says that
crime only exists because law
enforcement exists that's what that's
what we're hearing from black lives
matter hearing because our neighborhoods
are over policed that's why crime exists
but if you just took the police out of
the neighborhood's then the crime
wouldn't exist this fundamental
misunderstanding explains why rioters
torched a Wendy's in Atlanta on Saturday
night we'll get to that one second first
though I got to thank our friends over
at wise foods you know you know our
friends wise foods they've now renamed
themselves ready wise you've got to be
ready because having enough food to last
you in the event of a real food
emergency is kind of like having
insurance right you don't you don't need
it until you realize you need it and it
can save you and your loved ones and
looking around to society these days
seems like it's about time to stock up
so you know even on ready whatever
you've known wise company for years
they've changed her name to ready wise
same unbelievable product it is a better
time than ever to be prepared with
long-term nutritional food options and
ready wise has many options like
emergency meals freeze dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient Amigo
nutrition new adventure meals for hiking
camping other outdoor activities ready
wise meals they're easy to prepare
that's the first thing I like about them
you just add water they've got a long
shelf life very long shelf life so
that's another great thing and then my
favorite part probably is it tastes good
it's actually high-quality food go check
it out this week my listeners can get
free shipping at Riddhi wise com
when entering Noel's at checkout or by
calling eight five five four five three
twenty nine forty five ready wise as a
90 day no questions asked return policy
so there's no risk taking the initiative
to get yourself and your family prepared
today that is ready wise re ad Y Wis
e-comm promo code Knowles to get free
shipping this misunderstanding of the
left which thinks that crime exists
because there's law enforcement rather
than the other way around that's why
they burned down a Wendy's on Saturday
night in Atlanta so you probably saw the
scenes there was this fire engulfed the
whole Wendy's in the middle of Atlanta
on Saturday why did they do it
they did it because the cops use deadly
force against a criminal against a black
man that was the racial aspect of it
which is the reason they tied into all
of the riots and why why the Wendy's
burned down well what actually happened
during that altercation the way it's
being portrayed is that cops went up to
a man who is simply sleeping in the
parking lot and these cops
certainly stone-cold racists killed the
man for no reason is that what really
happened no how do we know that that's
not what happened we have body cam
footage and we have security camera
footage let's take a look I think you've
had too much to drink to be dry this put
your hands upon your back for me
okay and there the guy he breaks out
he's got two cops on him trying to
arrest him and this guy apparently
pretty strong busts out it's already
pretty clear he's drunk or on drugs is
on the ground the two cops are trying to
subdue him but they're not using a lot
of different techniques presumably
because if the cops use too much force
they're gonna have their lives
completely destroyed they're gonna be
accused of racism you're used to all
these things right so this guy obviously
strong as an ox is basically tossing
these two cops around finally he gets up
steals the cops taser
now still running away no use of force
turns around holds the Taser on the cops
possibly [ __ ] looks like he shoots weed
I don't know if he shoots or not but
does look that way and then the cops
discharged their weapons and get him on
the ground very sad scene why is it a
sad scene it's a sad scene because a man
died why did a man die did he die
because a bunch of racist cops went out
hunting him and shooting him down
or did he die because he was committing
a crime and threatening the lives of
those police officers stealing their
weapons and then unfortunately very
sadly had to be put down himself
obviously it's the latter the ultimate
reason that this is a sad scene the
ultimate reason that this man died is
because crime is a very sad thing
there's no there's no win here right
what's the win I mean I guess the win is
more people didn't die I guess the win
is there is some justice but it's sad to
watch nobody wants that those two cops
did not want to kill that guy how do we
know they didn't want to kill that guy
because they wrestled him they used
every bit of non-lethal force that they
could have four minutes beforehand and
then he pulls their taser and they still
don't use for us then he turns around
and points it at then I
I think pulls the trigger it's kind of
hard to see on the camera very sad stuff
and yet not one thing the cops did was
inappropriate if anything they were
timid in their use of force ostensibly
because of the environment that we're in
right now
then a bunch of rioters burned down the
Wendy's why'd they bring down the
Wendy's there I could see them burning
down the police station if they felt
this was unjust even though it
manifestly wasn't unjust you just heard
it you just saw it but let's say even
the the rioters didn't look at that tape
so they didn't know that the killing was
perfectly appropriate albeit sad what
what did the Wendy's do what did that
did the the manager of the Wendy's
participate in this no not at all this
burning this rioting has nothing to do
with justice okay no one could watch
that footage and conclude that that was
police brutality and the people who
burned down the Wendy's don't care about
the truth or justice they just want to
burn stuff down they just want to tear
stuff down great example of this from
London over the weekend there is an
activist and apparently an advisor to
the London police she was asked if a
statue of Winston Churchill should come
down because nothing screams Nazi like
Winston Churchill right the man who
killed Adolf Hitler yeah so she was
asked should this statue come down and
she said oh I don't know the question is
dependent upon whether or not Churchill
was a racist by whatever standards are
implied by that word today and then she
said I don't know if he was a racist or
not because you know I I never met
Winston Churchill he is the statue of
Churchill be there or not do you think I
haven't personally met him but what I
would be is that that question of
whether he should remain should be put
to the community she hasn't met him she
hasn't met him yeah well I hope maybe
she'll meet Winston Churchill before she
decides to tear his statue down
is there any oh no she can't meet him
because he died 50 years
and she has no idea who one of the
greatest Britons in all of history is
she doesn't know and yet she says it
should be put to the community
I mean basically everything she said
here is is crazy because consider that
she goes I am basically I have no idea
Winston Churchill is I know nothing
about British history and it should be
put to the community you know all of us
people like us to decide whether or not
to tear down British history people are
surprised she doesn't know who Winston
Churchill is I'm not of course she
doesn't know who Winston Churchill is
none of the people who want to tear down
the statues know who they are and know
anything about them the people who want
to tear down Robert II lay in the United
States don't know a thing about robert e
lee the people who want to tear down
Christopher Columbus don't know a thing
about Columbus and I have a little
insight into this in that I've given
speeches about Christopher Columbus I've
answered a lot of Q&A about Christopher
Columbus and no one who hates this guy
has any idea what they're talking about
and I'll ask them that and they'll sort
of admit they have no idea and they
think the burden of defense is on the
people who don't want to tear apart our
history but that's what they want to do
they just want to tear stuff down you
know the craziest things speaking of the
United Kingdom in Scotland a statue of
Robert the Bruce was vandalized with
with graffiti that talked about black
lives matter Robert the Bruce it's a
racist King is what the spray paint said
on Robert the but for those of you who
are not history buffs Robert the Bruce
is a 14th century Scottish King who won
independence from England the word
racism would have had absolutely no
meaning in the time of Robert the Bruce
the phrase black lives matter I think
Robert the Bruce a Robert there was
you're a racist he'd say what come again
before he would have said it with a
thicker bro welcome again he would have
I don't know I can't really do a
Scottish accent that's I think the
evidence that we need that this doesn't
have to do with any particular incidents
of police brutality real or imagined in
the United States or Great Britain it
has to do with a tearing down of history
if if Robert the Bruce is now deemed on
a
acceptable then we are not talking about
what people think that we're talking
about they want to tear stuff down you
know thousands and thousands of people
gathered in Brooklyn
over the weekend coronavirus is not
permitted in Brooklyn so if they're all
safe obviously they were there not
merely to protest for black lives matter
they went one step further down the
leftist oppression hierarchy they went
to protest for how black trans lives
matter and it turns out the object of
their protest is sort of the opposite of
the narrative that we've been hearing
we'll get to that in one second first I
got to thank our friends over a ring
speaking of security right now more than
ever my friends it is important to feel
safe in your home we're home more than
usual these days but it's hard to keep a
close eye on things right there are more
people knocking at your door that maybe
you don't want there I'm not even
talking about people who threaten your
life I'm talking about maybe it's your
mother-in-law maybe your mother-in-law
does threaten your life I don't know you
can check whether you're in your bedroom
whether you're on a beach somewhere
whether you're at the office you get
more deliveries and more deliveries mean
more boxes left unattended more
opportunities for packages to go missing
okay a lot can happen outside of your
front door you're not always there to
check on it in person well with a ring
you can keep your home safe no matter
where you are get a special offer right
now in a ring welcome kit when you go to
ring.com slash Knowles Keo wles what do
you get you get the ring video doorbell
three and chime Pro it's all you need to
start building custom security for your
home today how do you get it go to
ring.com slash no Skinner wles you know
I give this to my friends as a
housewarming gift the reason I give it
is it's great it's effective it makes
you feel like you're living in the
future
and for me most importantly it's not
very expensive ring calm slash Knowles
go check it out right now so thousands
of people gather in Brooklyn over the
weekend outside the Brooklyn Museum in
support of black trans lives take a
listen
[Music]
thousands of people for as far as the
eye can see all crammed in very tightly
together not social distancing talking
about the importance not just of black
lives or its Pride Month so it could be
gay or trans lives or whatever black
trans lives why did they do this why are
they telling this in with black lives
matter because there were two murders in
the past few days of black men who
identify as women and this is evidence
not just of racism but transphobia and
yet if you look a little more closely at
the cases themselves they undercut the
left-wing narrative so there were two
people murdered the first one was
realted Rhea Milton was killed
presumably for being a man who
identifies as a woman and this is
evidence of not just racism but
transphobia except that the two people
who have been arrested in connection
with the murder are named collab
Marshall twosome and Tyree Jeffrey cross
both of whom are also black men so this
actually has nothing to do with the
premise of black lives matter which is
that so there's this spate of anti black
racism around the country and black men
are being hunted down because of the
color of their skin the two people who
are now being charged with the murder
are black men as well so I guess this
could be a rally for trans rights or
something but the racial element just
isn't there no one about the other the
other man who identifies as a woman
dominique remy fells this happened in
philly they don't know who the killer is
yet but the Philadelphia Police
Department is investigating but we've
been just told that the police
department are the villains they're the
enemy so why how could we can't trust
them to investigate and yet they're the
only people doing any investigations
this this March or this protest in
Brooklyn was probably the biggest event
that we've seen in a week or two in
terms of a protest or even a riot or
looting or whatever it was the biggest
demonstration and yet
the the two central features of it the
racial element and the anti-cop element
don't make any sense
they're completely contradicted by the
facts of what they're demonstrating
themselves and this raises the question
this question a lot of conservatives
have been asking and some moderates and
nice people all around should we indulge
the premises of black lives matter which
the proponents of black lives matter are
presenting this is just simply meaning
that black lives matter and if you're
Pro black then you support it and if
you're anti black and you're a bigot
then you oppose it so should we indulge
this sort of thing or should we
recognize BLM for what it is which is
not what it says it is but actually just
a radical leftist Marxist
organization that was founded by radical
leftist Marxists who openly espouse
their Marxism who were funded by the
most radical left-wing donors on earth
who are highly organized and whose goal
is not merely to protect black black
lives as it were but to radically
overhaul society I think in my
presentation of those two choices you
can figure out which one I'm going for
it would seem pretty clear that this is
a radical group we will get back to this
question of do you indulge it do you not
indulge it just consider the the
different kinds of treatment so
thousands and thousands of people gather
in Brooklyn totally fine they're all
packed in really tight no big deal
meanwhile President Trump decides he's
going to reopen his rallies so he says
hey I'm gonna have a new rally you know
coming up in the next few days the media
furious this is the headline from NBC
News extraordinarily dangerous Trump
rally draws grave concerns from top
health officials now one hour before NBC
News tweeted this out they tweeted out a
generally approving tweet about the
Brooklyn demonstrations thousands gather
in Brooklyn for trans lives supporting a
good cause
then one hour later Trump rally draws
grave concerns from top health officials
no it doesn't it draws grave concerns
from leftist politicians and their hacks
in the scientific establishment and the
media establishment
Trump should absolutely hold his rally
they've lost their credibility at this
point the left in the media they can't
they can't do it they turn coronavirus
on and off completely at whim
willy-nilly they've turned it on and off
probably three times in the last week no
more I'm sorry we can't believe what
they say I wish we could believe what
they say but we can't they've proven
themselves to be liars and so I guess
we're on our own
Trump should definitely go ahead with
the rally there is a problem though
something I've got a ding the president
for I think he's undercutting his own
argument so Trump initially was gonna
hold this rally in Tulsa Oklahoma on
June 10th for those of you not familiar
with Juneteenth that's June 19th it's
the day that slaves were liberated in
Texas Trump Holt is gonna hold the rally
that day then he decides no there's an
outcry you can't hold the rally in
Juneteenth and you can't hold it in
Tulsa where there have been racial
tensions before you got to move the day
I was hoping Trump would stand firm
saying no way am i moving today but he
moved it he tweeted a quote we had
previously scheduled our mag or alley in
Tulsa Oklahoma for June 19 the big deal
unfortunately
however this would fall on the
Juneteenth holiday many of my
african-american friends and supporters
have reached out to suggest that we
consider changing the date out of
respect for this holiday and in
observance of this important occasion
and all that it represents I've
therefore decided to move our rally to
Saturday June 20th in order to honor
their requests we've already had ticket
requests in excess of 200,000 people I
look forward to seeing everyone in
Oklahoma its weak sauce man you know I
love the president you know I'm a big
supporter this was a very bad decision
to move the date not just a little bad
very bad why Juneteenth is the day that
the Republican Party freed the slaves in
Texas okay the party that the president
now represents president Trump has made
helping out the black community a big
part of his presidential administration
right lowest african-american
unemployment ever and he's touted those
kinds of statistics actually he passed
criminal justice reform meaning letting
people out of prison in large part to
show that he cares about the black
community I thought that messaging was
misguided but that was the that was the
point at least and now he's saying
now I can't possibly hold a rally on
Juneteenth he's giving the left the
premise he's saying to the left the left
the left initially says Trump you can't
hold a rally because you're a racist and
you hate black people and it's
disrespectful for you to hold a rally on
a day that celebrates freeing the slaves
and he said yeah I guess you're right
they're not right their premise is wrong
if anybody should hold a rally on
Juneteenth it should be the Republican
President there's no evidence that he's
a bigot at all there's a lot of evidence
to the contrary and yet he gave them he
gave them their argument I get it
there's a lot of pressure on him I can't
even imagine the pressure the
president's facing right now but you
can't give in you can't give in one
little bit
that's the point you can't give in one
little bit on the police you can't give
in one little bit on the funding you
can't give in one little bit on the
ridiculous racial narrative from the
left because when you give them just a
little bit you open the floodgates you
open the dam breaks and you get riots
and looting and racial division and
discord and we're seeing it all around
us now Trump is being knocked unfairly I
think for many other things as well so
he's being knocked fairly for the
Juneteenth issue he's being knocked and
for specifically for changing the date
he's being knocked unfairly though for a
bunch of other nonsense and it probably
gets to him after a while president rome
was giving a speech over the weekend and
he walked down a ramp and he walked down
a ramp i don't know like a little bit
slowly or something and the left is
having a field day i think that one's
gonna flip back on them it's gonna hurt
them in the long run first though i have
got to thank our friends over at
LifeLock speaking of security you know I
got to tell you something it's a real
hassle to have your identity stolen
luckily I've never had my identity
stolen I've come close I've made a few
mistakes friends of mine have had their
identity stolen and it's it's a disaster
okay well many people continue to work
from home on computers and devices we
have a large-scale phishing campaign
going on all right Microsoft right now
is warning that phishing emails which
appear to be coming from me Johns
Hopkins Center are trying to trick
people to open an attachment which is
disguised as a cove at 19 report which
then downloads a file
gives hackers access to your pcs okay
that's happening right now it's just one
example of the zillions of threats out
there
LifeLock detects a wide range of
identity threats like your social
security number for sale on the dark web
if they detect your information has been
compromised potentially they will send
you an alert no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses LifeLock
can see threats that you might miss on
your own that is why you gotta join
right now save up to 25% off your first
year got a life lock calm slash Knowles
Cana wles that's a life lock calm slash
Knowles Cana wles for 25% off used the
guys that I trust to protect my identity
so fair knock on trump total unfair
knock on from he's being criticized for
I walked down the ramp take a listen to
this so ok Trump is now he's finished
his speech
and he's walking sort of fine I mean
it's a you know it's a ram it's not like
there are stairs he seems to be a little
bit slower than normally he would walk
but obviously he doesn't want to trip
and fall the left would have a field day
with that then he comes to the bottom
has a little step at the end and he's
looking fine that's it and the left is
saying he looks like a doddering old
idiot or something if the left is gonna
try this line of attack against
President Trump when their nominee is
Joe Biden that's not going to work out
very well for them I think that by
comparison as president Trump told us
just a few months ago Trump looks like a
young vibrant man well I think that I
feel like a young man I'm so young I
can't believe it I'm the youngest person
I am a young vibrant man I look at Joe I
don't know about him I don't know
I would never say it when it's too old I
know they're all making me look very
young both in terms of age and I think
in terms of energy I think you people
know that better than anybody
yeah a young vibrant man and that is how
he looks you know Joe Biden was just
giving a speech and I guess it was sort
of a panel you know I don't even know
maybe he was trying to be a speech it
certainly didn't come off as a
particularly rousing speech and Biden is
sitting there with one of the face masks
dangling off of his ear it's not on his
it's not on both yours it's not covering
his mouth it's not on the table
it's just dangling off of one of his
ears while he tries to stammer his way
through an English sentence I don't know
not looking good it's just a little 11
second clip of the whole speech is more
or less of the same energy level and the
same coherence I'm not even gonna look
we know that Joe can't form an English
sentence I'm not even going to focus on
that I do want to focus on the mask
though because what what the mask shows
us here is that the mask is not
primarily a medical tool for preventing
the spread of a virus it is primarily a
political symbol obviously dangling from
the ear the mask is not gonna do
anything to prevent the spread of the
virus his nose as exposed his mouth is
exposed so why doesn't Joe either put it
all the way over his mouth or put it on
the table because the mask doesn't
really seem to do very much at least the
people wearing it like this don't think
it does very much medically but it's
signals to you that he's a good person
he's on the left he is taking the virus
very seriously except when it involves
racial riots then the virus doesn't
exist anymore it's it's merely a signal
to people of what side of the political
aisle he is on and and we've been making
that point on this show for weeks now
and the left has been attacking and
saying that's outrageous that's crazy
well there's your evidence there's your
evidence right there it he's wearing it
in such a way that it cannot possibly do
the thing that he's saying it does but
he's got to have it there any way to
signal who he is that wasn't even the
craziest part of the
Biden speech Biden then went on to make
a comment about the riots and protests
that is outrageous on its face and yet
actually practically Joe makes a pretty
good point he says that the effect of
George Floyd's death has been greater
than the effect of Martin Luther King's
death but even dr. King's assassination
did not have the worldwide impact the
George Floyd's death sure ridiculous on
its face I mean a lot of people have
focused on George Floyd's criminal
career basically you know George Floyd
was in and out of prison
he doesn't seem to have turned his life
around despite left wingers trying to
protest to the contrary obviously none
of that justifies George Floyd being
killed unjustly but people even some
people on the Left are pointing and
saying you know we shouldn't we
shouldn't turn this man into a secular
saint because that's gonna that's gonna
be contradicted by some of the facts of
his life okay compared to Martin Luther
King you know these two guys are are not
on the same plane and yet the point that
Joe Biden's making about the deaths of
these two men actually might be true the
death of Martin Luther King jr. did not
cause weeks and weeks and weeks of riots
and looting that were then defended by
the people who were running the elite
institutions that were then being sort
of granted as a premise that people
should loot to express their anger it
the death of Martin Luther King jr.
which was nationally dramatic did not
cause this intense radicalism that we're
seeing from the death of George Floyd
and it's not even a normative
observation right it's not saying we
should be reacting this way Joe Biden is
just saying that is the effect of the
reaction it's actually probably the best
point he's made so far in the campaign
we'll take a little bit of a look at the
effects of that and and who is pushing
the radicalism in a second there's a new
poll out that is that really opens the
curtain I think on who's pushing this
radicalism we'll get to that once
first I got to thank you for subscribing
to the Michael Nolt Show YouTube channel
we have officially passed drew Clavin on
YouTube subscribers this is very
important this makes me feel very good
we put a lot of stuff over there bonus
interviews segments breakouts we have my
Matt Walsh challenge that just came out
there about the woke celebrity cringe
video so go check that out we've got an
interview with Steve Dees of the blaze
also right now you know you're getting a
ton of lies from the mainstream media
sometimes you just got to go get the
facts where you gonna get that daily
wired.com you can get the readers pass
it's cheap guys it's three bucks a month
all right it's not and yet for you I'm
willing to take two-thirds off that
that's my gift to you just 99 cents for
the first month
head on over you get a whole lot of
great stuff a lot of in-depth analysis
so head on over daily wire.com slash
subscribe first month for 99 cents come
on back we got a lot more
big new poll out on the radicalism we've
seen in the past few weeks this comes
from Yahoo and YouGov poll asks a few
questions and everyone's looking at it
through the lens of race lens of race is
not I think the biggest finding here so
question what's a bigger problem in
America right now systemic racism and
policing or vandalism and violence
during the protests what's the bigger
problem in America the thing that the
rioters are ostensibly protesting or the
rioters burning down the cities
themselves when you ask people who make
less than $50,000 a year
49% say the systemic racism and policing
51% say the riots
so it's a slim majority but most people
say the riots are the bigger problem if
you make over a hundred thousand dollars
a year many many more people say it's
the systemic policing racism that's the
problem many many fewer people say it's
the riots 58 to 42 the big divide here
is not necessarily race the big divide
here is on income and it's the poorer
people who say the riots are the problem
and it's the richer people who say it's
the systemic violence and racism maybe
depending on how much you listen to the
mainstream media that's the opposite of
what you might expect next one do you
personally have racial biases yes or no
well if you make less than $50,000 a
year 15 percent say yes seventy-three
percent say no if you make over $100,000
a year 32 percent say yes more than
double and only 45% say no so fewer than
half say they don't have racial biases
the richer you are the woke or you are
is it okay for NFL players to kneel
during the national anthem right they're
protesting the American flag itself if
you make under $50,000 a year 49% say
yes that's less than half as if you're
not a math genius and 36% say it's not
okay if you make over a hundred thousand
a year sixty-three percent say yes 29
percent say it's not okay you're much
more likely to support the NFL
celebrities protesting our American flag
if you're rich than if you're poor again
might be the opposite of what the
mainstream media are telling you do you
support a riposte Colin Kaepernick when
he protested racial injustice allegedly
under $50,000 a year 38 percent support
37 percent opposed if you make over
$100,000 a year 55 percent support
36 percent oppose saying that we see the
same thing there same thing on questions
for the need for police reform reform or
defund the police this one to me is the
most interesting only 22% of people who
are under who make under 50 grand a year
say they support defunding the police
that number rises to 32% if you make
over $100,000 per year why because if
you make a lot of money you don't rely
on the police as much because you're
more likely to live in a nice
neighborhood where crime is not as much
of a problem and so what you say is you
want to defund the police which is
disproportionately going to hurt
minority people who disproportionately
live in lower-income neighborhoods this
is the this happens all the time okay
rich largely white liberals espousing
their woek social justice to end up
hurting poor racial minorities another
interesting bit from this poll just to
tuck away in your mind
Trump's Hispanic support right now is at
35 percent according to it which is
that's obviously going up against Biden
that's higher than the number is enjoyed
by John McCain or Mitt Romney even
though Trump is allegedly anti-hispanic
as he says he wants to build a wall and
cut illegal immigration he still does
better than political moderates
like Romney and McCain some people might
say rhinos or squishes he still does
better
turns out Hispanic voters especially
when it's up against Biden prefer
someone to be a little tougher a little
more conservative and stay with state
what they think no surprise the loudest
voices stoking the unrest and the
politically convenient race riots come
from rich white liberal celebrities
here's the video that took Twitter by
storm I take responsibility I take
responsibility
how you take responsibility I take
responsibility they all take respect
moment for every time it was easier to
ignore than to call mr. this we bless
every not so funny joke every unfair
stereotype every blatant injustice merci
every time our guests live in Hollywood
every time I explained away police
brutality don't know who that is or
turned a blind eye I take responsibility
you know that trillion more black people
are being slaughtered in the streets
killed in their own homes these are our
brothers and sisters our friends our
family we are done watching them die we
are no longer bystanders we will not be
idle enough is enough I will no longer
allow an unchecked moment alright cut it
there I'll cut it there you you get the
idea this goes on and on first thing
that shocked me is I don't know who most
of these people are which I guess is a
good thing because it means that
Hollywood stranglehold over the culture
is loosening up a little bit next thing
I noticed Julianne Moore just completely
wrong here black people are not being
slaughtered by racist cops or broadly
racist whites it just isn't happening
you can check the statistics Debra
Messing here clearly just reading from a
sheet of paper she did not even memorize
her sappy bit about I'm I'm taking
responsibility Aaron Paul is a worse
actor than we thought he was from
Breaking Bad I thought that guy was a
very good actor but his performance here
not so great but the key the key to this
whole video is is that last guy who
looks familiar but I don't recognize him
like I don't I don't know his name we
will not allow an unchecked moment you
heard it at the top that was the
original thesis of the video we will not
allow an unchecked moment what that
means is telling people to shut up if
they disagree with the left but checking
that's the checking is shut up
don't say that thing you think don't
voice that opinion that contradicts the
left is narrative and that's what they
want they want you to shut up
we want them to shut up but they want us
to shut up and it's not there just
mouthpieces for this left-wing
establishment they are insufferable
but even Dave Chappelle who is a very
good comedian came in and he got on this
this bandwagon supporting the peaceful
riots he did so for a sort of
interesting reason so he opens up his
new his new comedy set talking about
George Floyd not in a comedic way he's
just talking about it very seriously
then he criticized our friend Candace
Owens which also wasn't funny it was
just a vulgar kind of line it wasn't
even a joke then he defended these idiot
celebrities that we just saw giving
their opinions and it was kind of
interesting how he defended them because
he said people trust celebrities that's
why they keep going back and watching
them they do have an influence in a
platform and so it makes sense for them
to talk and I guess that's true we
shouldn't trust them for much of what
they have to say about politics if we
only know them for being good at
performing on camera you know if we only
know them for being good at reading
lines so the people have written for
them but we do and and that's a reality
in Dave Chappelle's acknowledging that
but then the most interesting part is
how Dave Chappelle defends the riots no
less than 400 police officers showed up
and answer the call boy let me tell you
something they Swiss cheese's he's dead
as dead could be he is done and you know
why 400 cops showed up because one of
their own was murdered so how the can't
they understand what's going on in these
streets we saw ourselves like you see
yourself Dave is actually making about
half a good point here and the thing
that's funny is because he attacked
Candice Owens in his set he then later
goes on apparently obliviously
to make the same point Candice Owens did
on identity what Candice Owens said in
her video was I don't identify with
George Floyd I know that people are
trying to say that I need to have racial
solidarity with George Floyd but I don't
identify with George Floyd and I
disagree with the decision to elevate
people who commit a lot of crimes as
representatives of the community that's
her point whether you agree with it or
disagree with it that's the point she
was making and so she's saying I
don't identify with him simply in the
basis of his race and what Chappelle is
saying is we must identify with these
people simply on the basis of their race
the reason why when when cops get killed
why the cops show up overwhelmingly to
take down the criminal which is the
first part of the story he's telling is
because they killed one of their own and
now when someone kills one of our own we
show out in the streets what is your
identity where do you find your identity
the left is trying to stoke all sorts of
identity racial identity no not white
identity but for every other race
they've trying to stoke racial identity
politics sexual identity if you're
attracted to men and you're a man or if
you're a man who identifies as a woman
they're trying to stoke that sort of
thing
class I didn't you know socioeconomic
class identity do you not make a lot of
money do you yes make a lot of money
they're trying to stoke all of these
kinds of identity and they're all pretty
shallow the one identity that they're
trying to destroy is American identity
that's why they're trying to tear down
the statues they're trying to stare down
not just robert e lee they're trying to
tear down Christopher Columbus and they
are going to tear down George Washington
where it hasn't happened already will
happen soon okay
that's the the only identity that in any
way can make this nation work is if you
have a strong perhaps even primary or at
least up at the top identity as an
American regardless of your race
regardless of your sexual preferences
whatever that is ebbing away I mean they
are now openly protesting the American
flag which is the symbol of that very
identity and they're stoking all of the
other kinds and even guys who are
usually fairly insightful or funny like
Dave Chappelle or agreeing with that
take on it where is your identity gonna
be that's the question okay is this
really a radical thing yes it is okay
they're talking about serious
destructive things you hear defund the
police and a lot of people are trying to
make sense of that the hill says what
does defund the police actually mean
okay that's that's their headline what
exactly does it mean to defund the
police that's from New York magazine
well the New York Times comes out and
actually admits it this is from the
organizer against criminalization
Maruyama cava what does that mean I have
no idea organizer against
criminalisation that's a good job I
wonder how much that pays mr. Soros how
much does that pay the headline
yes we must literally abolish the police
that's what they're talking about and
when they do that we're gonna be very
far gone it's gonna be very hard to put
Humpty Dumpty back together again when
you totally destroy law and order when
you defund the police when you destroy
your identity as an American and you
smash it up into little pieces and
you've got the black piece and the black
trans piece and the gay piece and the
Hispanic piece and the gay all of them
all the different little pieces you're
not going to be able to put Humpty
Dumpty back together again so we got to
be very clear about what we're doing
before we smash it when we smash law
enforcement we are smashing the order of
the country and then I think that's the
point of the radicals they're pretty
open about this they want to destroy the
order of the country and then put it
back together again in their own way
they want to smash a lot of eggs and
then make a new onlet all right this is
the rhetoric that we've heard all the
way going back to Stalin and Lenin and
even before that in in the face of all
of this you have some very well-meaning
people conservatives moderates
independents a lot of Christians a lot
of Midwestern Christians I've noticed
asking is it a good idea to just give in
a little bit to Neil is I I had this
discussion with a friend of mine last
night because some churches reserved
over the weekend and a lot of them are
buying the BLM radical line and they're
saying look it's actually an example of
christ-like humility to get down and
kneel to this political ideology you saw
those videos of the secular liturgy of
you know random white liberals kneeling
kneeling down on the street and begging
forgiveness of random black people they
know the brand of white person didn't do
anything to the random black person but
they're still kneeling down in this
liturgy is there is there an evidence of
christ-like humility here right Christ
turns the other cheek like Christ washes
people's feet Christ says love your
persecutors right Christ says all these
sorts of things take the worst seat at
the table I think that's why a lot of
nice well-meaning conserved
Christians in the Midwest are buying
into this stuff on the other hand it's
very unlike to acquiesce to evil and
Marxism is evil and black lives matter
or forget black lives matter whatever
the next Marxist front group is going to
be is evil - okay they're pushing very
evil things we went through the about us
section the other day on the show is
black lives matter about black lives
mattering no according to their own
website it's about destroying the quote
Western proscribed nuclear family it's
about creating a bunch of comrades it's
about pushing the same explicitly
Marxist revolutionary values that we've
seen for hundreds of years and those
about point of those values is not to
reform things a little bit it's to
utterly destroy them it's not to you
know change a little something about our
understanding of a statute it's to rip
down the statute it's not to reform the
police just a little bit it's to abolish
the police believe them when they tell
you that believe black lives matter when
the website tells you that believe the
New York Times when they tell you that
okay there is nothing humble or
christ-like or wonderful about
acquiescing to evil about acquiescing to
anarchists and looters and riders and
violent people taking over the country
and ripping apart the greatest
civilization in the history of the world
ironically the only civilization in the
history of the world that ever came to
oppose racism right but that's not the
point the race issue isn't the point
it's about totally undermining the
society are you gonna acquiesce to that
or not there's no middle ground there's
no but you're not gonna get halfway down
to kneel you're not going to give them a
little bit of their premises like
unfortunately I think even some people
at the highest levels of the federal
government are doing you're not gonna
get there's no it's yes or no if the
police the fund the police okay it like
abolish or order or maintain our order
with great strength those are the two
choices if you stand in the middle of
the road you are going to get hit by a
truck it is going to be the truck of
radical leftist revolution pick a side
this is not the time to go squishy order
will be maintained either radicals are
going to force it on us or we're and to
maintain it or
your choice I'll see you tomorrow on
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
Woodhouse key editor and associate
producer danny D'Amico audio mixer Robin
fenders hair and makeup Nika Geneva
production assistant
Ryan love the Michael Noel's show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20
you know the Matt Walsh show it's not
just another show about about politics I
think there are enough of those already
out there we talk about culture because
culture drives politics and it drives
everything else so my main focus is our
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about I
hope you'll give it a listen
you